hindsight is 2020 and here are 10 photos
that capture it
residents of lake tabore australia
looked on as flames burned through bush
four days into the new year
exacerbated by climate change the fires
claimed over two dozen lives and 27
million acres of land
celebrations of when britain officially
quit the eu on january 31st
featured plenty of union jack finery and
then the real work began to hammer out
the terms
mid-february doctors in the chinese city
of wuhan were examining the first waves
of patients
infected with a new coronavirus that
would soon become a global pandemic
over 1.5 million people would die from
it by the year's end
as if one plague weren't enough 2020
took yet another page right out of the
old testament
this photo was taken in kipsing kenya
the desert locust invasion across the
horn of africa
was the worst in 25 years and caused an
unprecedented threat to food security
protests against police brutality
erupted following the death of george
floyd in minneapolis
after floyd a black man died in police
custody
on june 30 china passed a wide-ranging
security law for hong kong
making it easier to punish protesters
and reducing the city's overall autonomy
a pair of explosions at the port of
beirut sent supersonic blasts through
the lebanese capital
killing at least 154 people wounding
5000
more and causing widespread destruction
the cause
and neglected stockpile of ammonium
nitrate
below russian opposition supporters
staged a flower protest
continuing the push for the resignation
of the nation's authoritarian leader
president alexander lukashenko there
were additional pro-democracy
demonstrations in thailand
hong kong and kyrgyzstan while it took
days to count all of the votes kamala
harris would go on to win the title of
first female vice president of the
united states
as well as the first ever to hold that
office with black or asian ancestry
in the indian village of thula sandra
puram where harris's maternal
grandfather was born
residents showed their support even at
the bus stop
and on november 9th bayern tech and
pfizer announced they'd created a coven
19 vaccine that was more than 90 percent
effective dr uslam tereshi and her
husband or
shaheen who founded bayern tech both
have parents who moved to germany from
turkey
the german husband and wife team have
been celebrated for showing what
immigrants and their children can do